armer les torpilles de trithérapie
d'antibiotiques
mon commandement la guerre contre le
virus du sida se poursuit
nouvel épisode dans ce conflit pour hf
prévention l'association yvelinoise a
dévoilé sa nouvelle application virus
war 2 une expérience où le mode la
réalité virtuelle pour essayer de tuer
l'ennemi dans un jeu ludique et
interactif
ça a été reproduit donc réellement c'est
à dire qu'on a vraiment les la syphilis
est vraiment la syphilis qui
représentait comme ça si on regardait
donc au microscope et vous allez le voir
quand on est dans le virus du sida et
qu'on voit le virus du sida il se
répliquent et donc c'est ça le danger
est donc il se réplique pour de vrai
aussi dans l'organisme utilisé le
virtuel pour mieux pénétrer le réel la
nouvelle application est principalement
dédié aux 15 à 25 ans un public qu'il
est difficile de concernés avec les
messages de prévention habituel si vous
aimez un film vous avez un film parce
qu'il vous provoque une émotion et donc
vous vous souvenez soit de deux tirades
de deux phrases entre deux acteurs parce
qu'ils vous ont provoqué une émotion le
game 'changer c'est un peu le même
principe on vous provoque une émotion au
travers d'un jeu immersif et ça vous
provoque une émotion qui vous permet de
retenir le message essentiel donc pour
nous d'en virer soir préservatifs et
dépistage l'association basée à trappes
a profité de ce lancement pour faire
aussi le point sur les autres
dispositifs qu'elle développe comme
l'application tubes pour trouver un
préservatif ou encore des autotests vih
qui permettent de savoir en une minute
selon les dernières données en france
trente mille personnes ignorent qu'elles
sont séropositives